I'm going to use the find method again. I need to find the
index of the person I want to move. In this example it would
be four. Then I need to remove them from that spot, so
that I won't have two copies of that person in the list. And
then the induces would change accordingly. Then once I've removed them, then
I want to add them at the front. I'm going to use add
instead of set, because I don't wipe to away the zeroth one,
I just want to move everybody down. So now this will be zero,
this will be one, two, three, four, five. In BlueJ that would look like,
get the Old Index, by finding the Person. And then if that Person is already
a friend we remove them from their old position and insert them into the
zeroth spot. If they're not already a friend, then we don't have to do anything.